we're headed in about a week and a half
all of us over to england
where there are protocols galore we're
going to be very safe i think and we're
going to shoot jurassic
world for the next three months yeah
what kind of protocols
are there going to be they gave us 109
pages they've invested
all their heart and soul and a lot of
money into making sure
that we're safe a reported 5 million
dollars is being spent on safety
including coveted testing for the actors
three times a week
due to england's production loophole
they'll avoid having to isolate for 14
days all alone upon arrival
we're all going to be quarantined in a
kind of a bubble all the crew and all
the cast
so far so good we know it's a a risky
time
but uh we feel it's uh it's good emily
do you feel comfortable with heading
over there i guess the kid you and the
kids are going as well
yeah we're going otherwise we wouldn't
see jeff for three and a half months
i felt like we would be safer being in
just like a small
bubble and not having any sort of
like temptation to like get out here is
your dose of cuteness for today
yeah check it out as my zoom with jeff
goldblum and bernadette peters turns
into a total pet
party right spike now the two are
helping find homes for furry friends
with the 22nd annual broadway barks
across america
which streams tomorrow this is
definitely my wife there's
here's charlie and charlie here's buddy
can you see what he
here we go oh there's wood buddy
[Music]
all the poodle poodles are the best
what's this
what are you showing her what are you
showing up
ready and me i'm walking on the leaves
oh
gosh that is beautiful rachel here's
rosalie
say hi moon it's my charlie
oh oh charlie isn't he beautiful
let's talk 22nd annual broadway barks we
have jeff
and we have carol bernabeu jackman lynn
manuel miranda
so many performers love animals john
hamm he's on this
too so much love comes out of them and
we need that right now we need all this
love to come out into the world